hey guys so okay let me turn my music
down because i'm a complete idiot and an
apple watch obsessed
dare i use the word idiot again i am
gonna go
to one of the only places in los angeles
that is currently
going to be selling the apple watch in a
retail store i think there's a few other
ones but richard ryan is there right now
and
i it's late but i mean he's camping out
there along with a bunch of other people
so i'm going to go just swing by say hi
it is let's see it's 10 37 right now
it's completely way past my bedtime but
i'm gonna go say hi why not i mean like
it doesn't actually even matter like i
would just be going to bed so instead
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna say hi this is so exciting i'm
like
my heart is racing because i'm excited
for everyone in line and i know what
it's like to be first in line and to be
sleeping on the street for something but
i will say that these guys have not been
here for two days which
is tragic but here we are
the line
oh my god
hello
are you guys excited
i'm i'm so excited for you i don't think
there's gonna be enough watches at this
retail location for people to get
one hello
we've got a live broadcast going on
right now
abc richard ryan oh mr first in line how
does it feel uh it's a little chilly so
i had to throw throw the camo digs on
very nice thank you guys very much
appreciate it
he just he just photobombed your your
your vlog here he did but it's okay
because you were just on live tv
so which one are you getting you just
have to
just have to check it out on the channel
maybe
i know and i'm very excited for you i'm
i'm nervous yeah nervous yeah this one's
nerve-wracking but i think you're gonna
be our own
the light the light just got better yeah
it did it looks great for me awesome no
you look good now you're silhouetted so
where are we right now this is max field
so when you said you're a max build i
thought it was a max build apple store
so i was googling maxfield apple store
i'm like this is not an apple store this
is not apple store yeah everybody
thought they were going to be camping
out inside of a mall but instead or in
front of a boutique fashion store that
apparently nobody's ever heard of i
haven't heard of it okay let's rephrase
it yeah the average person has a hurdle
i think it might be a little too fancy a
little too far yeah but we're here and
this is one of the only retail stores
that's actually going to have the watch
so it's kind of exciting and i think
that hello hello
you know they're just scoping out the
line just to see what's up it's may
sweet yeah
what time did you get here
and what time do you get here 1 30. 1
30. so you're 8 a.m let's let's finish
i was just stalking
i know and i didn't i actually didn't
update anybody on twitter that mine is
coming tomorrow so i should probably do
that
now they care but it's okay they'll find
out tomorrow because what been talking
about so this is exciting there's like
there's a good amount of people here
it goes all around so i'm gonna get
worse as the night goes on yeah and i
hate to break it to them i don't think
they're gonna have enough watches here
for all these people so
not my problem
oh yeah i don't remember why i parked so
i'm i i was too excited i just like
there's the park right here on the
street well this is exciting so i look
forward to you guys all getting your
watches tomorrow yeah thank you thank
you
oh my god i'm so excited i can't wait
for apple watch tomorrow or today or
whatever you guys happen to watch this
video i'm so excited uh that's it i'll
see you
guys oh
whatever